[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous lundi 19 février
bienvenue pour une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de ce set 8 journal une
école intercommunale à la prochaine
rentrée en septembre la maternelle jean
de la fontaine elancourt accueillera
également des enfants de maurepas
solution avancée face au manque
d'effectifs d'élèves
l'établissement sera composé de cinq
classes plein reportage dans cette
édition
le dossier était bloqué depuis plusieurs
mois le projet de l'aménagement de la
zone gare bécane à la verrière et
relancer les élus de saint quentin en
yvelines ont validé la décision vendredi
dernier en conseil communautaire mille
logements sont prévus et des
constructions qui suscite quelques
inquiétudes pour la ville voisine de
maurepas et puis ils sont dans le
dernier carré les footballeurs de
plaisir se sont qualifiés hier pour la
demi-finale de la coupe des yvelines de
football victoire 3 buts à 1 face à
maule à suivre le résumé de cette
rencontre électrique
et puis dans ce journal également invité
alexandre langlois qui est agent du
renseignement au service à départemental
du renseignement territoriale des
yvelines il viendra nous parler de ses
missions mais aussi des conditions de
travail en tant que délégué cgt digi cgt
police nationale c'est un entretien à
qui est à suivre
c'est le premier de l'année le seuil de
pollution atmosphérique aux particules
fines a été atteint aujourd'hui lundi en
ile de france celui qui déclenche la
procédure d'information afin de réduire
les émissions de polluants le préfet de
police de paris fait quelques
recommandations est notamment réduire sa
vitesse sur route différer ses
déplacements en si possible et emprunter
les transports en commun alors je vous
parle ce lundi soir l'épisode de
pollution ne devrait pas se poursuivre
cette semaine je vous en parlais dans
les titres les norvégiens et les élans
courtois ne seront plus seulement
voisins à la rentrée 2010 8 certains
d'entre eux seront également aux
camarades de classe les deux communes
ont décidé que l'école maternelle jean
de la fontaine
streit intercommunale un moyen de faire
face au manque d'effectif des écoles
sujet de mélanie poker quentin le frère
à jean de la fontaine les cinq classes
seront bientôt complètement occupé en
septembre 2018 les élans courtois
accueilleront des mortes à bien un
projet mené par les deux communes
première école intercommunale de saint
quentin en yvelines avec deux écoles qui
perdent des effectifs et on n'aura pas
de constructions nouvelles dans les
années qui viennent et donc au lieu
d'avoir justement l'école de la ville
parc avec seulement deux classes depuis
la rentrée 2016 avec des interrogations
des parents qui sont légitimes sur
l'avenir de cette école la maternelle de
la ville pâques accueille actuellement
48 élèves s'échangeront d'établissement
et ne parcourront qu'une dizaine de
mètres le problème sur la fontaine c'est
qu'on a deux classes le vide
ville parc c'est pareil donc c'est ça
qui entraîne que bon voilà on va pas il
faut exploitent ces deux équipements
sont sous-exploitées c'est là c'est
donc le constat est là la solution vu la
proximité des deux communes aussi bien
un nom de domaine est que en termes de
méthode ou en termes de culture
ça semble évident de fectivement de
rapprocher ces deux écoles pour mort pas
ce changement s'inscrit dans le projet
génération la ville parc accueillera en
septembre 2019 les tout-petits de la
crèche des au boulot destiné à être
réaménagé pour devenir une résidence
pour seniors développeur expert en cyber
sécurité et data community manager les
métiers liés au numérique se développe
et des profils très convoité par les
entreprises qui ont pourtant du mal à
recruter c'est pour répondre à cette
problématique avec vient d'être signé la
convention école du numérique
partenariat entre saint quentin en
yvelines et les organismes de formation
du territoire l'objectif c'est
d'identifier lister les cursus en
rapport avec le numérique
treize formations sont d'ores et déjà
labellisée école numérique ce qui
représente 250 places disponibles on va
être un symbole un peu de cette nouvelle
culture numérique qui impacte qui va
impacter 80% des emplois
donc on est là pour accompagner cette
transformation numérique et en même
temps on remarque que nos entreprises à
saint quentin sont des entreprises de
plus tôt 2 2 de haute technologie et qui
nous disent qu'elles ont un déficit de
recrutement ya eu par exemple cinq mille
propositions qui n'ont pas toutes été
satisfaites
parce qu'il ya un manque de formation
dont vaud n'a pris le taureau par les
cornes comme on dit et on a créé des
structures qui vont former 300 personnes
en accéléré avec une culture numérique
gremm opérationnelle de l'entreprise
la prochaine étape ouvrir une école
spécialisée du numérique à saint quentin
en yvelines qui regroupe aurait l
ensemble des formations toujours à saint
quentin en yvelines la reprise du
dialogue acté entre l'agglomération et
la verrière le dossier d'aménagement de
la zone gare beckham égard bécane pardon
et relancer ce projet urbain était
bloqué depuis plusieurs mois du fait de
son importance les nouvelles
orientations votées en conseil
d'agglomération vendre
dix ont permis de reprendre la
construction cette construction à terme
de 1000 logements
certains élus restent tout de même
inquiets les précisions avec nicolas
kirillovitch une nouvelle version du
projet gare bécane après plusieurs mois
de blocage les élus de l'agglomération
et la vie de la verrière sont finalement
parvenus à un accord pour relancer le
projet principale nouveauté la
construction de 1000 logements contre
1800 initialement quand vous avez un peu
trop gros projets de densification ça
des effets bien sûr sur les autres
communes donc il ya eu des échanges
jusqu'à modifier faire évoluer le projet
donc s'est-il 4 sur soi c'est nos
objectifs qu'on a gardé qu'on a un con
qu'on re défini autrement mais sont les
mêmes objectifs
parce que c'est important d'avoir on a
été élu sur un programme on n'a pas été
aidé sur un autre programme adopté en
conseil communautaire les nouvelles
orientations du projet ont suscité de
vives discussions entre les élus et je
rappelle que le seul axe structurant
route de la zac du week-end ce sera la
départementale 13 1 cinq des six
conseillers communautaires de maurepas
se sont abstenus pour cette délibération
inquiets notamment des répercussions
d'un tel projet pour leur ville je
m'inquiète en tant que maire de maurepas
sur les impacts qu'auront ces
aménagements sur la ville dans le futur
et comment les nouveaux habitants
vont-ils circuler dans cette nouvelle
zac et aux alentours
je j'entends aller craintes d'impact que
ça peut avoir mais à travailler il n'y a
pas de nom solution au problème
la nouvelle évolution du programme
urbain entraîne une reprise des études
du projet celui ci devrait permettre
d'établir une part de logements sociaux
à hauteur de 25%
aucun calendrier en revanche n'est
encore fixée pour le début des travaux
un invité m'a rejoint en plateau
alexandre l'emploi bonsoir bonsoir on va
avoir l'occasion avec vous de parler
d'un sujet peu évoqués dans nos éditions
celui du renseignement territoriale
alors je précise que vous êtes agent du
renseignement au sein du service
départemental du renseignement
territoriale des yvelines mission
sécuritaire ô combien importante on aura
l'occasion d'en parler
vous êtes également délégué syndical
vigie cgt police nationale on évoquera
également donc les conditions de travail
des agents de ce service dans le
département
déjà pour bien définir les choses
quelles sont les missions d'un agent au
sein du renseignement territoriale alors
on a quatre grands axes de mission on
halak ce dont je fais parti qu'est le
ski s'occupe de prévoir les
manifestations sociales et culturelles
enfin qu'il ya des débordements sur la
voie publique organisée et encadrée
quand il ya une grève comme une
association culturelle qui fait une
manifestation on a une branche qui
s'occupe plus de la lutte contre le
terrorisme avec toutes les dérives de
radicalisation et dérives sectaires
on a eu notre branche qui s'occupe de
tout ce qui est contestation politique
violente dans les extrêmes droites
gauches et enfin nous avons un dernier
petit volet b dans les îles
qui est important du fait que le
département soit proche de paris de la
protection des personnalités qui
viennent dans le département c'est
restrictif déplacement d'une
personnalité politique président de la
république un ministre
il présente la république un ministre un
élu voilà du monde soit un élu de la
république ou des invités ce que des
fois y'a des ambassadeurs qui vient à
versailles nous sommes sur les
dispositifs alors dans vos missions il
yal'idée aussi vous l'avez dit
d'anticipation c'est de prévoir
finalement d'éviter grâce à aux
renseignements que vous avez pu
collecter sur le terrain des menaces à
la sécurité publique c'est ça exactement
nous travaillons donc il ya deux
services de grands services de
renseignement en france la dgsi qui
travaille plus sur dur un segment
technologique gironde a tendance à
confondre
quelles sont les différences entre les
deux services d l'asile et s'il
travaille donc c'est les méthodes de
travail le plus la plus grosse
différence a déjé sitra et sur des
méthodes technologiques avec internet
filtrage des réseaux communication etc
d'accord avec une segmentation des
informations circulent chaque agent de
renseignement à la dgse site traite une
information ni par exemple vous portez
la valise de tels points à tel point et
vous ne serez pas pourquoi vous l'avez
fait ni ce qu'elle contient il ya
d'autres personnes qui font ça aux
renseignements territoriale on est plus
basé sur le renseignement humain car nos
sources c'est ce que vont nous n'y avons
protect les gens les bailleurs sociaux
les élus les les syndicalistes toutes
les personnes qu'on peut rencontrer qui
vont nous donner de l'information
humaine est normalement les deux sont
complémentaires ce que le renseignement
humain permet par exemple ce qu'ont dit
les dans le par exemple pour le
terrorisme les plus dangereux ils vont
se réunir en paye en liquide donc
impossible de les filtrer sur les
réseaux bancaires et monstres et nuire
au fond d'une cave donc impossible de
mettre des balises ou quoi que ce soit
donc s'il ya quelqu'un dans l'immeuble
qui le dit attention une réunion un
petit peu louche ni faire un tour
personnel en retirant normalement c'est
complémentaire c'est à dire que ce n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui
à l'heure actuelle c'est vraiment
compliqué de travailler avec la dgsi
pour des raisons de méthode c'est à dire
que nous venons l'information passe
directement chez eux par contre eux pour
avoir une information de chez eux ça
peut prendre plusieurs mois ce qui fait
que dans le monde du renseignement c'est
très compliqué d'autant plus que
normalement une académie du
renseignement a été mis en place pour
être ensemble la dgsi le renseignement
militaire la d
à des gse compagnie mais laurence et moi
territoriales pour le moment n'en fait
pas partie hawks étaient au programme
donc tout ça mais des problèmes de
coordination d'autant plus qu'au niveau
national
on a lu clad qui gère la lutte
antiterroriste qui en classe pour être
précis union à force de parler en 6 et
un traitement c'est quoi c'est la
gestion de lutte anti terrorisme au
niveau de la police d'accord au dessus
de nous avons aussi également le l'état
major qui était en place par monsieur
cazeneuve et maintenant nous avons la
task force de monsieur macron ce qui
fait qu'à force de faire des échelons et
un mille feuilles
leur hausse est moins de terrain peut
être pertinent mais après comme il ne
sera pas traitée ce que tout le monde
pour soi sans quelqu'un d'autre qui
veulent traiter on arrive à des failles
énormes pour qu'on aimerait bien que ce
soit vraiment simplifié et coordonnée au
niveau national juste pas d'apprécier un
bernard cazeau bien sûr ancien ministre
de l'intérieur et des gestions on le
disait depuis tout à l'heure c'est la
direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure alors vous le disiez donc
dans l'émission recueillir traiter les
informations
comment vous voulez recueilli justement
ces informations par quel travail sur le
terrain ben a rencontré les les acteurs
locaux
quel qu'il soit donc à la fois
d'associations syndicalistes que je
disais des fois que les journalistes on
travaille aussi qui peut voir des
informations les élus en tant qu'élus et
pas en tant que parti politique ce que
nous nous sommes les héritiers des
renseignements gerry nérée ou mais
depuis 1995 nous ne faisons plus de
politique malgré un mythe persistant et
donc en comptant tous ces gens là ils
vont nous dire voilà on va faire si on
va faire ça et après elle le il ya des
réseaux sociaux aussi qu'ils sont une
mine d'information et de veille
informatique au niveau national au
niveau local parce que finalement ce
qu'on dit toujours en rigolant le plus
beau officier de police pour les
services de renseignement c'est facebook
au fait où les gens mettent eux mêmes
les informations dont on a besoin sur
internet après aussi
toutes ces informations sont prononcés
pour qu'on puisse prévoir les événements
les empêcher les faire le nécessaire
dans les différents secteurs qu'on a
évoqué donc ça vous le faites à partir
d'une mode c'est ça une fois que vous
avez recueil de renseignements il ya une
note qui a édité jarrier une note
qu'elle dit et qui part au niveau
national central qui sera traité et au
niveau local si une répercussion sur le
département donc si jamais par exemple
sur un événement social une
manifestation une grève quoi que ce soit
on prévoit l'événement c'est combien y
aura de personnes et le jour j on est
présente pour le bon déroulé de
l'événement la même chose pour le suivi
des notes de antiterroriste et
radicalisation diverses liées note qui
paraît si la personne et sur le
département et a voué à rester sur le
département on fera un suivi quotidien
de son environnement ou un truc est
régulier suivant les moyens du bord pour
être sûr qu'il n'y a pas de débordements
est ce que nous sommes a service les
gens n'ont pas encore fait de fautes en
général accor niveau de l'antiterrorisme
c'est qu'on les surveille
au cas où il se passe quelque chose mais
voilà c'est de la prévention plus que de
la pression sinon ils soient jugés et on
voyait devant la justice on le sait une
mission très importante au combien
importante et en vue de ce contexte
aujourd'hui de menaces terroristes
quelle est la situation la du
renseignement territoriales dans les
yvelines est ce que c'est une situation
qui a été difficile aujourd'hui
alors c'est difficile parce que le
renseignement territoire et par rapport
aux renseignements généraux n'est plus
une direction indépendante cirque dépens
de la sécurité publique et notre budget
a été en général fait pour aider les
commissariats la sécurité publique qui
gère les commissaires est donc tout le
budget qu'on avait propre a été un peu
fait pour renforcer dans d'autres
branches vous souhaitez vraiment la
catastrophe
donc on arrive à des choses on manque de
véhicule on manque de moyens
informatiques
on a beau j'en ai discuté avec un député
il était atterré de savoir qu'on avait
des ordinateurs bloqués voilà par
exemple cet été on peut aller consulter
les sites par exemple vente privee.com
et la banque rothschild par contre faut
demander l'autorisation pour les sites
sur tech sur l'extrême droite l'extrême
vous alerte y est déjà de cette
situation il ya deux ans juste avant
tout la vague d'attentats a volé les
attentats de novembre 2015 voilà on
avait déjà alerté donc ça s'est pas
améliorée depuis que nous aux brousses
tour les budgets on nous dit qu'il ya
toujours pas de choses il ya quelque
chose qui était encore un peu plus
embêtant récemment on avait fait des
prévisions très juste au niveau du
mouvement des la pénitentiaire donc sur
les yvelines est plus pertinent sur le
secteur je travaille avec la prison de
versailles et la maison d'arrêt de bois
d'arcy et on ne vais quand même aller
sur consigne du coup du renseignement de
la préfecture de police tous les matins
même si avait rien pour au cas où s'y
passe quelque chose donc on a
l'impression d'être un peu
décrédibilisée notre travail parce que
notre enseignement est précis un travail
d'information avant et quand on va sur
le terrain pour vérifier quelque chose
on sait qu'il va rien se passer
au mieux il se passe rien et c'est ce
qu'on a dit et le pire c'est qu'on peut
se décrédibiliser par rapport à nos
contacts qui n'ouvrait diesbach qu'est
ce que vous faites là on vous a dit
qu'il y aurait rien donc on puisse on
passe pour des guignols
dernière chose il nous reste moins d'une
minute emmanuel macron à présenter en
septembre dernier un plan anti
terrorisme dans lequel était prévue une
simplification des dispositifs de
renseignements ou à la plus de
coordination également il ya eu aussi
cette mesure de la police de sécurité du
quotidien qui a été annoncé entre temps
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
dispositifs
il ne reste pas beaucoup de temps et
qu'est ce que vous attendez finalement
se corse quand ce qu'on a vu c'est un
mille feuille supplémentaire qui n'a pas
vraiment d'efficacité opérationnelle sur
le sur le plan antiterroriste monsieur
maquereau en plus avait dit dans son
discours aux forces de sécurité
intérieure qui avait fait un plan à
trappes
en fait c'était un quiproquo il n'avait
jamais rien demandé il ya jamais une
plante e-tourisme attrape et enfin la
police de sécurité du quotidien en tant
que service de renseignements d'un hôtel
et beaucoup parce qu'avec des
renseignements supplémentaires de des
patrouilles de terrain avec un contact
chrono avec la population et à l'heure
actuelle on se dirige vers tout sauf sur
ça et encore moins dans les yvelines vue
qui a même pas eu de concertation avec
la mairie trappe par exemple qui est
concerné donc plus de moyens aujourd'hui
c'est ce que vous demandez pas des
moyens supplémentaires et surtout de dd
budget propre
une indépendance pour travailler pour
éviter aussi ce qu'on peut retrouver des
noces service donne des informations sur
certains quartiers sur certaines villes
le commissaire du coin a besoin pour sa
carrière d'informations différentes et
du coup en tant que service mais sous
direction du département
nos avis bien que réel ne sont pas pris
en compte pour des déroulé de carrière
statistique va merci alexandre langlois
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle vous
êtes agent au service départemental du
renseignement territoriales et des
yvelines délégué syndical pour donc les
syndicats vigie et cgt polices
nationales merci d'avoir été avec 6
revient à saint quentin en yvelines où
vous l'avez peut être remarqué les
abords de la gare ou changer de visage
la passerelle qui reliait le lieu à
l'immeuble international a été détruite
c'était samedi il s'agissait d'un
élément historique de la ville nouvelle
sa disparition marque un tournant dans
le réaménagement du quartier camille
lambert et patrick jacques de dixmude
quarante mètres de long et 190 tonnes de
béton a découpé en trois parties
un chantier qui ne passe pas inaperçu
dans ce quartier de la gare très
fréquenté la rue stephenson à montigny
le bretonneux a été fermée à la
circulation pour permettre la
déconstruction de cette passerelle
enlevons par levage progressif en trois
tronçons distincts pour la poser au sol
et pouvoir ainsi procédé à la
déconstruction du béton le plus gros des
colis faisant 78 la distance à laquelle
on doit la poser au sol a nécessité la
présence d'une grosse grosse grue de
levage
une opération spectaculaire pour une
passerelle est historique
cela faisait quarante ans qu'elle relier
la gare de saint quentin en yvelines
l immeuble internationale ce dernier
sera entièrement réaménagée en deux
parties vingt mille mètres carrés de
bureaux et 130 logements
nous avions en charge le curage du
bâtiment donc nettoyer tous les
bâtiments restitution du béton nu
ensuite des vidéos grosse opération de
désamiantage à ce genre de bâtiment
ayant énormément d'amiante et la
déconstruction de parties de bâtiments
en vue de la reconstruction de nouveaux
logements ribes l'euro afin de déblayer
la passerelle la rue stephenson restera
fermée à la circulation jusqu'à vendredi
les travaux de démolition de l'immeuble
se poursuivre jusqu'en avril d'ici là
l'avenue de la gare est modifié il
faudra attendre 2020 pour voir le
nouveau visage du quartier
autre lieu autre site historique pour le
territoire le technocentre renault
implantée à vue en cours depuis à 20 ans
l'an passé à l'instar de toute
l'industrie automobile française la
marque au losange a obtenu des records
de vente + 8 5% une filière qui
poursuivra sa croissance et celle du
véhicule électrique
interview au technocentre de nicolas
dans le riz et patrick jacques de
dixmude on en voit de plus en plus sur
les routes les ventes de véhicules
électriques ont augmenté de près de 44%
entre 2016 et 2017 en europe en france
31 8 véhicules ont été vendus en 2017
et c'est la voiture zoé qui est en tête
sur le marché européen et pour en parler
elisabeth delval bonjour alors vous êtes
directrice programme adjointe pour le
véhicule zoé au technocentre de
guyancourt
alors déjà un premier commentaire par
rapport à ces chiffres et cette
croissance du marché du véhicule
électrique
oui effectivement donc aux renault et
pionner leader en europe sur les ventes
de véhicules électriques
et cela pour la troisième année
consécutive et donc zoé et
également la voiture la plus vendue en
europe et donc en 2007 donc les ventes
de jouets ont fortement progressé et par
rapport à 2016
on est à + 44 % également sur les ventes
de zoé
alors comment peut-on expliquer ce se
succéder des véhicules électriques et
notamment de la zone en fait jouer c'est
un véhicule grand public
je rappelle qu'on a la deuxième
génération de batteries sur zoé
donc on a la meilleure autonomie avec
300 km d'autonomie réelle en usage
urbain et donc beaucoup de gens font le
pas vers le véhicule électrique
alors comme je les dis vous êtes au
technocentre de guyancourt au
technocentre renault de guyancourt
alors concrètement qu'est ce que vous
faites au quotidien pour le véhicule zoé
donc effectivement le technocentre au
groupe toutes les équipes ingénierie
programme du véhicule électrique donc on
travaille au quotidien pour développer
la gamme pour améliorer les performances
autonomie charge coût est également
pouvoir vendre sur de nouveaux marchés
c'est à dire donc globalement donc
aujourd'hui nous avons une gamme avec
quatre véhicules
le twizy et la zoé un kangoo z2 et une
sm 3 et 2 qui est sur le marché coréen
très prochainement en france
nous allons lancer le masters et 2 qui
va être commercialisé dans les quelques
semaines à venir et nous allons
également renforcer notre notre position
sur de nouveaux marchés notamment la
chine avec un petit véhicule électrique
abordable sachant que la chine c'est le
premier marché en matière de vente
électrique
combien vous êtes ici à travailler sur
the zoo à seysses le chiffre serait
compliqué parce qu'il ne fait
qu'augmenter
je pense que vous avez certainement
entendu dans le cadre du plan
stratégique 2022
on veut continuer à élargir sa gamme
donc ce chiffre ne fait qu'à évoluer
donc et je sais pas vous donner un
chiffre car il est en continuelle
croissance alors sur quelle partie du
véhicule on travaille ici vous parlez
d'un générique c'est quoi en fait on
travaille surtout sur le la partie
mécanique la chaîne cinématique la
batterie là le système de charge et de
toutes pièces sur tout ce qui constitue
un véhicule
normal quoi donc effectivement on
travaille sur toutes les technologies
électriques et donc vous embauchez le
technocentre de guyancourt embauche
alors quel poste sur quels postes par
exemple on embauche effectivement sur
sur des postes très variés qui vont
depuis j'irai des postes orienté sur la
chaîne cinématique les technologies
liées à la batterie l'ethnologie lieu
aux motorisations les technologies liées
aux services connectés donc les postes
sont assez larges cinématique vous
pouvez expliquer à tester la chaîne de
traction d'accord alors c'est des
chiffres les chiffres que j'ai donné au
début de la situation du marché du
véhicule électrique sont quand même à
relativiser parce qu'ils représentent
que 1% du marché du véhicule
comment pourrait-on booster en fait
cette filière on va la boue c'est comme
je le disais en élargissant aussi notre
offre qui est déjà aujourd'hui tu as
quatre qu'on va doubler à terme avec lui
huit véhicules électriques et comme je
disais également on va améliorer on
continue à améliorer l'autonomie et les
temps de charge pour que finalement
signé plus de frein à l'achat d'un
véhicule électrique
or certaines personnes disent que c'est
peut-être un peu cher le véhicule
électrique est ce que comment
pourrait-on démocratiser ce type de
véhicule mais en fait c'est finalement
au fur et à mesure que les ventes
augmentent on cherche également à
baisser les coûts et rendre ce véhicule
de plus en plus abordables donc c'est
effectivement ce principe qui va
s'appliquer de plus en plus dans les
années à venir
sur quoi vous travaillez actuellement
pour l'avenir notamment jeu par rapport
à vos véhicules zoé mais on continue à
développer et à renforcer la gamme je
peux pas vous dévoiler le programme à
venir sur nous et plus précisément mais
comme je vous parlais des principaux
axes de travail donc autonomie charge
donc ça va faire partie du programme
future 2e et puis vous vous préparez
aussi sûrement pour le salon de
l'automobile 2018 je suppose
oui pour ceux qu'on se prépare pour tous
les salons de l'automobile de 2018 sur
le véhicule électrique
elisabeth delval merci beaucoup merci un
mot de ce sport à présent on jouait ce
week-end les quarts de finale de la
coupe des yvelines de football plaisir
s'est qualifié pour les demies
après un succès contre maul le résumé de
la rencontre avec michael we draw match
des grands jours ce dimanche 18 février
à plaisir le club local affrontements
pour une place en demi-finale de la
coupe des yvelines équilibrée sur les 45
premières minutes le match des blocs
juste avant la mi-temps après ce but
inscrit par l'attaquant kevin l'orphelin
c'était dur on l'appelle au caucase on
appelle beaucoup d'occasions mais le
plus important de façon c'est d'avoir
mis le but 1-0 pourrait être obligé de
se découvrir et je pense que c'est là
qu'on est les meilleurs
une fin de première période idéale sur
laquelle l'entraîneur plaisir oie s'est
appuyé pour construire son discours à la
mi-temps ne pas s'énerver poser le
ballon et jouer surtout voilà c'est
vraiment notre qualité sur laquelle on
s'appuie sur de plus les milanais donc
et puis je pense qu'ils sont un peu
stressés donc vraiment détendre tout ça
message non reçus par les joueurs les
plaisirs wa nerveux ne parviennent pas à
ressortir le ballon et commet de
nombreuses fautes
sanction immédiate moule revient à
égalité après dix minutes de jeu en
seconde période
un avantage de courte durée plaisir
reprend la main sur penalty après ce but
la tension change de camp les jours de
maule durcissent le jeu plaisir à
l'occasion de tuer le match à plusieurs
reprises la libération viendra
finalement dans les arrêts de jeu le
héros du jour mamadou syma qu'on s'offre
un doublé sur penalty de penalty c'est
la chance on va dire ça c'est rentré
c'est rentré et voilà tout c'est un
joueur que qui revenu au club ya trois
ans et qui cette année
marche très très bien après on peut
retenir une prestation que d'un joueur
je pense que c'est l'ensemble de
l'équipe qui a été très très bonne non
on fait le boulot ça a été difficile
match un match assez compliqué on le
savait face à une belle équipe de maule
très très beau match plaisant et on a
réussi à gagner donc c'est important
d'aller l'aller en demi-finale en
demi-finale plaisir affrontera mort pas
une équipe qui évolue en d1 de district
une division dessus des plaisirs oit la
rencontre se disputera le dimanche 1er
avril dans le chaudron du stade bernard
jérôme hallé on referme ce journal sur
une autre fête celle ci plus est
déjantée bruit de moteur et odeur de
gasoil ont envahi à vendredi
le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 8e édition de
la butte h party une soirée mêlant moto
concert est également faite sur laquelle
revient mélanie poker je suis là soit
parce qu'elle est la lumière une poche
suis rentré et de la lumière il y en
avait pour 7 buts edge parti vendredi
soir le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines avait pris des
allures de circuits moto on permet aux
gens d'un petit peu lâcher prise mais
toujours dans le temps dans un espèce de
journée on est tous des sportifs
2 de sports extrêmes
quand gérard notre manière les risques y
a pas vraiment beaucoup de risques parce
que la piste va pas très vite et tout ça
donc on essaye de canaliser les gens
dans un bordel ambiance années 60 70 ou
presque et la beach party c'est simple
un dress code du sport un concert une
absence totale de sérieux que je suis un
prix nobel de débilité et entre prix
nobel on se comprend et on s'est tous
rejoint ici ce soir est super bonne
ambiance et voilà c'est gentillet et
c'est cool trois amendements
super il ya de l'ambiance de belles
d'image c'est top
à saint quentin en yvelines c'était la
huitième but edge partie mais la
première en ile de france près de 250
buteurs sont venus s'affronter des
pilotes qui n'ont pas froid aux yeux
même haleine pendant dix ans
[Musique]
mais voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8
journal bonne soirée excellente semaine
à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]